what is your
what is your outlook on the
the future of the us and foreign policy
and these regime
changes and these wars in the middle
east especially with
if you know if biden is the president
now
and and who he's going to surround
himself with
are you optimistic are you pessimistic
how do you feel about it
i'm not looking forward to a sharp
change in the way america approaches the
rest of the world
since the end of the second world war
the united states has had the view that
we need to be the dominant power
everywhere on earth
at the end of the cold war around 1990
we had a chance to recalibrate
our approach to the world and accept the
fact that
the world could be multipolar and we
didn't we
won our ideological battle uh
and we shouldn't insist on continuing
the struggle for full spectrum dominance
as they call it in washington but we we
pushed ahead on that project we decided
we still wanted to control the world
nato which was the alliance created
soviet union didn't dissolve
when the soviet union fell apart in fact
it got stronger built a new building and
took on all kinds of new missions
uh so i don't think that biden
is going to take the united states
out of the mindset that we have to be
the dominant power in the world
and that we know what's good for the
world
better than the world itself knows that
principle is always guided american
foreign policy
now that said i can see that there could
be some nibbling around the edges
i can't imagine for example that there
will be a slight
decrease in tensions between the us and
iran
they have reached such crazy levels in
the last few years
uh that they might be able to be dialed
down
hopefully back to the level lease that
they were four years ago
which wasn't very friendly but at least
we didn't feel we were on the brink of
war um
i'd like to i i'd like to see and i
think i would expect to see some changes
in the u.s
relations with cuba there have been some
very intense new
sanctions just imposed uh that prevent
cuban americans from even sending
remittances back to cuba i could see
biden lifting those
i could see him taking the united states
back into the world health organization
uh back into the paris uh climate
control
climate accord um but
that he would fundamentally re-examine
the question
of whether the united states needs to be
controlling
places all over the world i see that as
far-fetched he's very much a
product of the american foreign policy
establishment
remember that biden has spent his entire
adult life as a senator in washington
he was chairman of the senate foreign
relations committee he
voted for the iraq war and was a leading
promoter of it
because as chairman of the senate
foreign relations committee
biden had the chance to call witnesses
who would have testified that going into
iraq was a bad idea
that would have given americans the
other side of the argument
but biden never caught those people as a
result
an entire side of the argument the
argument that it was not a good idea to
invade iraq
never got a platform and i attribute
that largely to biden as chairman it was
up to him to set up the witness list
so um i i do
the product of the traditional foreign
policy orthodoxy in the united states
but i would
add this caveat
the american people and the voting blocs
in both parties
are increasingly in favor of a more
restrained
foreign policy a number of public
opinion surveys show this
the only place in the united states
where there's still a little
appetite for foreign wars and foreign
intervention is washington d.c
the public has left this behind they
don't want to do it anymore
but washington is so fueled by foreign
money and foreign pressures and
all sorts of imperial fantasies that it
can't
break this addiction now
biden to my mind is not a person of
deep ideological or passionate
conviction
and the same goes for kamala harris
they're pragmatists they don't have
deep beliefs so i think they're willing
to be
shaped by circumstance one of those
circumstances
is that the public and including the
base of the democratic party
doesn't want to continue these constant
foreign conflicts
and i think if there's enough pressure
from below
if the uh res forces
favoring restraint and limited foreign
policy
can organize and show biden
that this is where the party is now
that might have an effect and uh
although i
i'm not optimistic about the kinds of
people that he's going to appoint to
national security jobs i do think that
he
will evolve and feels public opinion
evolves and that gives
those of us uh who
have a voice the rest ability to show
him that public opinion
is not where it was when we launched the
iraq war almost 20 years ago
now i heard you mentioned briefly on
another podcast that you did
that pr obviously there was a lot of
presidential candidates who were very
outspoken on foreign policy
like tulsi gabbard and bernie sanders um
is it true that when a president wants
to implement
domestic policies versus foreign
policies
there's a lot more hoops they have to
jump through with
like congress won't let them enforce
their
their tax laws that the changes in like
taxes or universal health care
or education but when it comes to
foreign policy it's much easier for them
to get things done
well let me answer that if i tell you a
story
i once had the opportunity to spend an
hour
sitting around chatting with jimmy
carter it happened that he
actually came to nicaragua while i was
the new york times bureau chief there
and he wanted to see me and we had a
very nice chat
and here's one of the things he told me
he said when i became president
i decided i wanted to consult with all
the living former presidents
in private and just have a chat with
them about what's it what do you do how
do you do this job
how do you be president what advice do
you have for me so i brought them in
very quietly and we had
private conversations since i brought in
nixon
and i said to him what's your advice on
how to be president
and nixon told me you know something
domestic policy is too frustrating when
you come into office there's going to be
a problem with education
is going to be a problem with housing
this is going to be a problem with
health care
there's going to be a problem with
public welfare when you leave for office
it's those problems are still going to
be there yeah if you can do something
you can nibble around the edges but it's
so frustrating
you've got congress you've got so many
vested
interests and issues are so complex
you appoint yourself a good
environmental protection administrator
and a good
housing secretary and tell them to do
the best they can but
world affairs is so much more fun
because there you can really get things
done
all you have to do is sign a piece of
paper and your policy towards the whole
part of the world changes
so i i always kept that story in mind
and i think it's very true um
these things that progressives talk
about like uh
medicare for all or um let's say free
uh tuition in public universities
uh i think those seem like no brainers
but those are really difficult projects
to get done
we saw what it went what we went through
with obamacare
it was tormentous and then it came out
as
a grotesque caricature of a health care
bill because so many different interests
had to be
accommodated in foreign policy it isn't
like that
look what president trump did with iran
with one stroke of a pin
he pulled the united states out
of a profoundly important deal that was
going to
not only prevent iran from ever getting
a nuclear weapon but lay the basis for
some long-term stability in the middle
east with one
signature he got rid of that he
abolished that so
it tells me that biden also can do
much much more incomparably more in
foreign policy than he can in domestic
policy certainly uh
in the short term and the short term is
very important now
because we don't know what's going to
happen in four years you know one thing
we saw with trump is that you can rip a
whole structure apart very quickly
so this puts i think a different lens on
foreign policy
it has to be looking for somewhat
shorter term
returns now you can't just set in motion
a policy hoping for a return in 20 years
which is what good foreign policy should
do because you don't know what's going
to happen
with the next spasm in american domestic
politics
therefore i don't expect dramatic
changes from a biden administration
i'm looking at the people he's bringing
into government
as more or less the obama crowd
and uh you'll remember that obama
dropped more
bombs than george w bush and was
involved in wars in seven countries and
set libya on fire and help
devastate syria um so
i don't see a change in basic
mindset i can see
some of the excesses to which uh
trump pushed us being uh moderated
but a true re-examination
of whether it makes sense for the united
states to spend its resources
policing ukraine and the south china sea
and everywhere else in the world
i don't see that
you